this is genuinely the most horrific
video i've ever seen
and we can show you virtually none of it
it's islamic state propaganda for sure
it shows young boys
being trained to fight but more
importantly it explains
why these are not just errant boys
in the video they hunt down and kill
prisoners
for real
they've been brainwashed and they are
deadly
the question is will they always be
because in the chaos of the mosul battle
many of them are on the loose
sky news has been given extremely rare
access to some of those
who've been caught or are suspects
some were identified in the sprawling
refugee camps dotted across northern
iraq
and turned in a dozen or so share a cell
they're well treated and spend their
time praying and trying to learn english
that's an english dictionary
their stories are similar reluctant to
join islamic state they're groomed by is
members
to take up the calling of jihad and
ultimately
martyrdom mahmoud is 12.
he
[Music]
he said he was terrified at what was
happening
and tried to leave
foreign
for the families of this lost generation
these are difficult times
they come to visit their children aware
that they could be sentenced
to 15 years or longer in prison and the
families themselves could be ostracized
in the days after islamic state has gone
their meetings are short and not very
private
but the kurdish authorities holding them
will take no chances
with the terror threat of the 236
inmates here 215
are suspected of terrorism and there are
camps nearby
overflowing with young men whose
intentions are unknown
the curse of islamic states hate-filled
messages
and doctrine of pure evil could take a
generation
at least to pass stuart ramsey sky news
northern iraq